Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. And Ah,
I'm just checking in on you.
I'm just checking and just seeing
how your week's going, you know,
you know, I would think if I
was in New York Yankee Fan,
despite the fact we're only a couple
of games up for the one game playoff,
I would say that I'm having a pretty
good fucking Thursday. You know,
you see the last couple of games? Did
you see last night's game in particular?
I'm gonna tell you guys right now,
I am going to gradually wean
you off of watching ESPN,
Fox sports west,
listening to the fan.
Okay?
Nobody gets it right?
More Times in my own mind,
in my own world, without doing any
research on how any of those other people,
how many times they get it right?
Nobody gets it right more than the
manual listening to right fucking now,
what the fuck did I say? Well, Bill, you,
you've said a lot of things. All right,
fair enough. I have said a lot of things.
If I mentioned this fucking wires sucks.
Jesus Christ.
God forbid I turn my fucking,
this is unbelievable. It's
a brand new fucking wire.
Does anything work?
Is this how like China is going to slowly
like they know they can't fucking bomb
us, right? So what do they do? They
just make everything just a little bit,
not fucking right and it just, it's going
to gradually drive him fucking crazy.
Now what do I do?
I've got to move this thing over here.
Bring this up because God forbid
there's any weight on this wire.
The second thing is weight.
All of a sudden it doesn't work.
Now it totally does it. Come
on. I need to hear myself.
I need to hear myself talking about how
great I am. All right, there you go. Um,
I told you motherfuckers, I love how I'm
mad at you guys. Like you ever said no,
you didn't bill, you never told
us that. Right? Fuck is my water.
Oh Jesus, this is going to be one of
these doll. There it is. There it is. Um,
I told you way back in fucking August
when the red sox swept the Yankees and
ESPs are fucking over.
What's over ESPN.
Oh,
I guess maybe a divisional race.
Who gives a fuck?
You know what I mean?
There's still the wild card
still the fucking wow.
That's like there's an ax murderer outside
you fucking house and you just lock
the front door and you leave the
back door wide open. You're like,
well I guess that takes care of that.
Not to mention if you have a wood door,
you know,
but so motivated axe murderer,
he could just chop down the door.
Okay.
That actually would work in your favor.
It gives you time to try
to find something to defend, you know,
defend yourself is acts, you know,
tactically speaking will
be a little more dull
cause he'd gone through the front door.
But this is all beside the point.
I told you mother fuckers back then I was,
I can tilt David Price goes into the
fucking mellow folk and [inaudible] God
goddamn game.
I don't give a fuck that were out
there sweeping the Baltimore Orioles.
All right.
Regular season stats.
You know what that's like?
That's like the guy who was the fucking
big man on campus in high school, right?
He's a fucking lie.
He's a captain of this.
He's got the dimple in his fucking chair
and he's banging a fucking cheerleader,
right? And everybody's like,
oh my God, Hey, she's going up.
Or you're the president right
now.
What happens?
You go back to the reunion and
he looks like may no, he got me.
I'm just saying
like it doesn't make a difference if
you win 89 games or fucking 129 games.
What murders is how you're doing against
the fucking teams that you're going to
see in October.
You know?
But that's not the business that does
those so and so's over an ESPN and Fox
News and whoever else. I'm, I'm
lumping into the same fucking category.
That's not the game they're in.
They're in the game of what the
fuck you see is what the fuck it is.
And we will hype the shit out of
it and not even remotely look at it
analytically. So then if what
happens happens, you can be,
like I said,
it was going to happen,
but what you said was going to happen
doesn't happen. Then you get to do though.
What happened?
Yeah.
What happened was you got a namerd by a
bunch of fucking victories against the
Orioles in the fucking tigers. A bunch
of Steve's or Jacob. I mean huge guys.
Gate gate hit black over 9,000 homerun
junior regular season, and yeah,
we're absolutely anemic in the
playoffs. Well, yeah. Well,
how did they do against
the fucking Astros?
Sorry.
Anyways, you know what? You know what
that's like the, it's like watching Paul.
I love Paul the death.
I got to get him on the,
I have to get him on this fucking podcast
because I'm always making fun of them
and I want you guys to know that it
comes from a place of love. All right?
Most of the times it comes
from a place of love,
but right now it comes
from a place of concern.
Okay. One of the dumbest fucking
things that you can do. Yeah.
Besides buying a fucking Goddamn
fucking speaker wire. I'm,
I'm blaming it on China. Okay.
It's a, it's always a great guest.
Everything's fucking made over
there. All right. It's like when,
when you get you eating a
doughnut, you're like, what?
What's the main ingredient ingredient
in here? The one guests you have is corn
corners in everything.
If you don't believe me,
watch the one documentary I
ever watched about food and
have now are using that as my Bible.
I saw it years ago,
so I'm probably misquoting it.
All right. Having said that, no,
what I just said was effect.
One of the dumbest things you could do
is the first game of the week bet a bunch
of fucking games.
All right?
And I'm not talking about fantasy shit
and I'm not talking about all the people,
the sports gambling,
podcasts that I read a advertising.
Then I told you to go out and
do that exact fucking thing.
So this would be hypocritical now for
me to tell you this, but I, you know,
you don't know who the fuck anybody is
until about two, three fucking weeks in.
All right?
I've tried to tell Paul Versey this.
Paul Versey is the king of
betting football college or pro.
In fact,
when I first became friends with him back
when college football wasn't brilliant
enough to realize that they needed to
have some good matchups in the first few
weeks to get people into it, to pull
them away from the NFL. And this,
this is what's happening. You know, even
though I haven't looked at the ratings,
okay, I'm saying it's happening,
therefore it is happening. Okay.
Now these goddamn feminists and me tours
can just say things happen without any
evidence in God. Damn it. I can say
this is happening with no evidence,
no research, no nothing to write
fucking college football is, is,
is getting better ratings right now
than the national football league.
Dare I say a presidential address.
Okay. Now, if Netflix doesn't
have to give out ratings,
then why should I have to look
at him? That's what I say. Um,
anyways, Po Po, uh, this is like
10 fucking years ago, 12 years ago.
And at first knew Paul, this is back
when they had all the cupcake games,
you know,
to establish the rankings for whatever
reason they would have like Ohio State
Doh play, uh, Eleanor Rigby,
fucking nursing home, right?
Nursing School of nursing or some shit,
right?
And then they would be favored by like
fucking 80 points and fucking Versie
would go out. And just the first
week of football, you know,
being a college coach is so much
harder than being a pro professionals,
uh, coach. Simply because every,
you know, three, four years,
you've got a brand new fucking team.
You're just constantly,
every year is a fucking rebuilding year.
And now all these Goddamn millennials,
which they're not millennials once again,
1980 to 1995,
there are 23 to 38 years old.
I actually just told a 38 year old woman
yesterday that she was a millennial and
she couldn't fucking
believe. I say, yes, you are.
According to the one website that I went
to and didn't even look at a second one.
Even back it up. You are a
millennial. And she said,
I don't identify as millennial.
And I was like,
are you angling for your own bathroom?
Um,
I don't know yet.
You know I'm doing this right now cause
I don't even know what the fuck's going
on in the world right now.
I just know it's a fucking,
everybody is in a Goddamn
hissy fit about everything.
So I just know,
and I know that you don't need evidence,
you don't need fucking anything.
People just say things and then it's
not only the person that did the thing,
it's the person that stood next to
the guy that did the fucking thing.
So in the future,
God forbid God for fucking bed,
you're standing on the subway platform
and somebody jumps in front of a train to
commit suicide.
Um,
they're going to blame you for assisted
suicide because you stood there and did
nothing.
I'm sorry. That's probably a slight
exaggeration. Probably a bad, you know,
I probably should've read up
on the story a little more.
I probably don't know what I'm talking
about. I probably won't even upload this,
but I might. But if you're
listening to it, you know are dead.
So Versie would go out
and he fucking would just,
just the first week of college football,
you have no idea who the fuck anybody
anybody is. And he would just,
he would just do it. It's a lot.
I mean, it's literally a joke.
Nebraska given 58 and he'd
fucking bet on the favor. Right?
He's doing it again this year.
All right.
Last week he fucking bets. Uh, you know,
he's got that fucking homecoming theory,
a good road team coming off a loss
playing the next week, add home.
He doesn't give a fuck how many
fucking points they're given.
He can't lay off it.
So he keeps calling the lions, that
hapless lions, that hapless lines.
It's just like, dude, they,
their first game of the year,
they had a shit one. Okay,
everybody's going to have a shit game.
The fucking patriots just had a
shit game against the Jaguars,
but it was week two. So nobody is
saying that that's who they are.
But last year they had a shit game against
Kansas City and all of a sudden the
whole for all the wheels were off.
The Tom Brady era was over.
And what ended up happening all Tommy
Brady brought us right back to the fucking
super bowl. He threw for 500 yards
over 500 yards in the game and he lost
was our defense suck
that game, you know? Um,
okay.
Because they will, they only held,
nick falls to over 300 yards,
which I guess was a great day.
If the other guy threw for 500 birthday
or the day we don't come out with
victory than money to me.
MMM.
So last week for his, he's telling
me that the lions, the hapless lines,
you take Jimmy g coming home,
San Francisco,
it's a lock and he's texting me, the whole
game is San Francisco is winning. Say,
what did I say? I set it all
week. Exclamation points.
He's an absolute euphoria that he said
something that now look
like it was going to happen.
And he's looking at Matthew Stafford
like this fucking guy likes to lose every
week. Like, this guy
doesn't have any pride
like this man can't get out
there and slam that fucking rock.
Okay.
The next thing you know,
the fucking lines come back in the end
and they end up covering the spread.
No, we've all fucking
been there. All right,
so you learn from your past.
Well, if you learn from your past,
you wouldn't keep gambling,
but now you come back for more.
What does vars do again this week?
He's teasing the Patriots.
They play, I think that they play,
I don't know, somebody playing,
he keeps calling them the hapless lions
because they had one bad fucking week.
So now the lines are playing. The
Patriots are former fucking, um,
coach is coaching the team.
He's been when he went and what
meant fucking Patricia? They're like,
that guy doesn't know some
of the shit that we do.
Yeah.
Okay. Now I'm not saying the Patriots
won't go in and kick the fucking shit up.
I don't, I say the pages. Okay. All right.
So I don't know what the fuck I'm safe.
I'm just saying,
you just lost betting against his fucking
tape and you're still calling them the
hapless fucking lions.
They were on the road.
They almost beat the fucking 40 niners
they had one bad fucking game.
Yeah.
All right. And this brings me back
to the fucking red sox. All right?
They sweep the Yankees in the beginning
of August. Did everybody fucking,
all these guys in these
fucking sports shows,
they put their tasseled fucking
loafers up on the desk, you know,
fold their fingers on top of their
head and that's fucking over.
It's so, it's, it ain't
over. It's not over.
It's not fucking over. So my
prediction, the Red Sox, uh, yeah.
I just don't think we,
we don't have the fucking one two punch.
We don't have a one and two as far as
I'm concerned in our starting rotation
that you need.
You know,
we just don't have it.
So I think we're going to win a bunch of
fucking games and then we are going to
lose in the playoffs.
I don't want that to happen.
I didn't want to say that to you.
I don't want to ruin your fucking day,
but you know,
okay.
Until a price starts fucking
winning and Yankee Stadium,
I just don't fucking see it.
Unless we're going to play for straight
fucking game or I'll, I'll, you know,
only have them start at home.
Oh my God.
I love the guy.
He's a fucking amazing picture and
everything and I really needed him to win
last night. I needed it. Okay. I
needed it because, you know, I,
I, you know, I lived through
sports. That's, that's how,
that's what I do. Okay. There.
Okay.
Does that make you feel better?
It's not enough that I'm a 50 year
old man alone in a room right now,
talking into a microphone,
hoping that somebody listening,
nodding in agreement almost didn't get
through that word. Listening, listening.
Um, and we'll have things
you'll want to talk about.
I will too.
This is like my own Mr. Rogers show.
You know,
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood,
a beautiful day.
And the neighbor here comes the
current through the fucking door.
He has always wanted to be
right about something in sports,
even though it has no effect on his life.
So let's all fucking listen to this shit.
Yeah.
Send them some emails and say, dude,
that was it. You figured it out.
Your genius. Go Fuck yourself
yet. Redcurrant sorry. Um,
go fuck yourself. Go Fuck Yourself.
I always have to finish the song.
Please go fuck yourself.
You freckled count. Um, anyways,
uh, I have not been watching
the news and been working.
I'm writing a script right now,
so I haven't been watching anything and
it's fucking hilarious to not watch the
news to not what's no,
what's going on because all your friends,
it just constantly are just
sending you texts. All caps.
Are you watching this or they call
you up though? Did you see this?
Did you see that Mark Cuban thing?
Okay.
Did you see what Trump said?
Did you hear about the fucking Albatross?
Yeah,
the Dj Dj's. Did you see what happened
in Bolivia? It's fucking hell.
It's never anything good.
Never. Never anything fucking good. Um,
anyways, so I, I don't, I
don't know what's going on.
I did watch the Mark Cuban thing for
like a minute, man. That was fucking,
that was brutal.
That now that, that right there, that
that's uh, that's one of them brutal once
they ain't no, maybe there's,
they know, maybe that's just
straight up. That's just
fucking Jesus Christ.
I don't know. You know, I got to
tell you here at this podcast,
like that's not the way we
run our business here. Now.
The genius of my podcast is there's,
there's nobody else here.
Therefore I can't get in trouble.
I don't send emails to myself.
At no point will I ever be on the
ESPN of podcasting, sitting there,
shifting,
uncomfortably,
trying to answer questions
that I have the answers to.
I just don't want to tell them
to you because I know it's, it's,
I did the wrong thing. Um, or maybe,
maybe in the future they'll, they'll
be something like that. You know,
I want to see what is a woman
going to be fucking squirming.
What about that woman
who fucking date rape?
The 17 year old guy who
fucking was talking all that
shit about Harvey Weinstein
and then she fucking paid the kid
off and then blamed it on a dead guy.
Okay.
Where,
why isn't she shifted around?
Ask it answer and fucking uncomfortable
fucking questions. You know,
sometimes it's deer season,
sometimes it's elk season.
I guess it's still deer
season. I can't wait. When,
when is it going to flip up?
When is it going to flip around?
MMM.
That's why I don't look at this shit.
I saw this woman,
she wrote it in like Twitter.
She's just like, oh, this one guy,
he was able to come out back after
fucking six months. It wasn't six months.
It was close to a year. So they
already fucking shaved off some months.
And uh, Monica Lewinsky wasn't able
to come back for 20 years. It's like,
what are you talking about? And she
goes, and she did nothing wrong. Well,
I think Hillary would
probably debate that.
MMM.
It's like she hosted SNL. She wrote a
fucking book. She had a line of purses.
She had a show. They tried to
get on the air. She not only,
she fucking became a cottage
industry off of that thing.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
MMM.
Anyways, I dunno, I that's,
it's just like this,
this fucking thing that women
are doing that with all,
they just keep peeking over the fence
and all this scene is green grass.
You know?
I, I don't, I just don't fucking,
it's like what are you looking at?
That's all you see.
You only see green grass.
Yeah.
Engage fucking show up and people just,
Kevin Stop for Guy did something wrong
and nothing happens if a be 30 rock,
it sounded like fucking five-year-olds.
I'm not saying there aren't
double standards, everything,
but like why didn't you pick one that's
actually a double standard so you don't
have to fid shit that sends you a whole
thing is just going to fucking collapse
or maybe you do research. This woman
actually said she's on her fucking stump.
She's saying after the Monica Lewinsky
thing that Bill Clinton was those then
reelected. It's like he wasn't,
it happened in his second term.
Do a little research. I mean,
what? What? What do you mean
[inaudible]
and we'll have things
we'll want to yell about.
I will
to,
um,
when a woman brushes your teeth,
she can feel the whole
toothpastes community judging her.
When a guy brushes his
teeth, they're like, oh,
we should run the company
next time you're in traffic, stop and go
traffic ladies. Just, just look at the,
look on the guy's faces.
Look at the cars they're driving
to.
Any of them look like they're even in
remote control remotely in fucking control
of their lives.
Ladies,
be honest with yourself,
okay.
In the average relationship,
boyfriend, girlfriend,
okay.
Married.
Whatever life partners the end of the day,
okay.
If she wants to get brunch
in the guy doesn't, what the,
what do you think you're going to do?
What is the guy's options?
Does he have any at the end of the day,
who's really calling the shots?
If only one person has life insurance,
okay.
If there's only one fucking person
that's going to benefit from the other
person's death on average,
who is that person?
Huh?
Let me come on people.
Happy wife. Happy life. Where's
the cute little rhyme for the guy?
There isn't one.
It's cause we don't matter.
Yeah.
Look how they hate Valentine's Day.
It's all about the woman.
Why?
Because they know that every guy is
living the fucking male female dynamic,
which is keep it happy.
Maybe it will fuck me.
Keep it happy.
Maybe I can watch the game.
Maybe I can enjoy 20
minutes of my weekend.
That is, that is the world.
Most men are living it.
But if you go on the Internet
and you go on social media,
most men are blocking a doorway while
jizzing on a plant and running a company
telling you when you're in traffic,
just look, look, it's, I'm telling you,
you just look at the side of somebody's
head and you know who the fuck they are.
You can see how much hope they have left.
All right?
Yeah,
I challenge you.
Why does that thing doing
that shit now I challenge you.
I challenge you to find a lot of hopeful
fucking guys out there. Did you see the,
yeah.
Did somebody else tell me that?
And I actually looked it up that fucking
that was that woman out there, uh, in,
in Hawaii telling men did just shut
up and do the right thing for once.
It's a fucking, she's hold political
office and it's just talking like that.
Just shut up and do the right thing.
All the guys asking for is,
is to him to say his side of the
story. She's basically saying, shut up.
Don't listen to the guy side of the story.
As this woman says,
all these things that's going
to destroy this guy's career.
I'm not saying what the woman's saying
is true or isn't true, but the guy,
he doesn't even have the
right to defend himself.
Jay Jay Dang for once.
All right. How about we do that when
you push away from the buffet table, Oh,
there's a nice low blow for
you and I am proud of doing it.
I'll take the 10 minute misconduct.
That's what it's becoming.
It's becoming literally shut the fuck up.
All guys shut up and listen to one side
of the fucking story and then that's the
story.
The story is my story.
Your story doesn't count
because you have a fucking Dick.
That's the world that
we're going into right now.
And evidently it's like progressive.
It's fucking insane. It's insane.
Yeah.
And right now, if one of these
crazy women listen to this,
they would completely twist what I just
said and say that I'm actually against
women who've been abused,
getting some sort of justice,
which is not what I'm saying.
I'm just saying that there you have to
listen to both people and then weigh the
evidence.
You know,
even that is a flawed fucking system,
but it's the best system we have.
And now you're going to take that system
and you're going to throw it out and
now you just,
you know,
it's like Frankenstein movie that
fucking coming up the hill with torches.
Um, just shut up. And as you could
tell them a little emotional,
you saw like she had that whole fucking
thing planned out. Like she, you know,
she thought she was got to
get like a bunch of hits,
which I obviously did if I
fucking heard about it. Um,
yeah, I dunno. It's literally, it's
like McCarthyism meets a fucking,
myspace is what's going on right now.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
I should show up in everything works
out when we show up to hear your,
okay.
Meanwhile, the average guy who's
driving some sort of shitbox to work,
working for somebody else
in a job that he never really dreamed of
happening is a kid that's most people's
fucking reality, but not on
social media, social media.
Every guys out there running a company
eating steak and lobster for fucking
lunch, make it as secretary, shower
her tits. Like that's what's happening.
That's what all that and every
soul, every guy out there, shut up.
Hm.
How dare you try to defend yourself
and everything you worked for. Shut up,
do the right thing and shot up.
Um,
just a comedian me, I can't lay off this
shit. It's so fucking funny that like,
you're literally watching women's reaction
to abuse of power and now they have
power and they instantly start
abusing it. I mean, it's just,
it's just completely going off
the fucking rails here. Um,
and most people,
male and female understand that.
But all of us are too afraid to tweet or
say fucking anything because then like,
cause then you have to
literally apologize.
I watched somebody in my business have
to go on an apology tour for literally
having an opinion. He was an innocent man
who hadn't done anything fucking wrong.
He just had an opinion and he had to go
out and apologize for having an opinion.
Yeah.
And we'll have things you'll
want to talk about. All right.
Felix Gray,
everybody
the average American blast their eyes
with bright screens for 11 hours every
day. Oh yeah. There you go.
Live in the dream, right.
Staring at a fucking computer.
Um,
now you can protect your eyes with a
pair of Felix gray glasses available with
or without a prescription.
I have a pair of these.
I have a pair of these fucking things
and I can tell you they are, if you,
if you're looking at a computer for a
long fucking time and you don't want your
eyes to be doing that little jumping
around thing, this is the solution.
Felix gray glasses filter out
90% of high energy, blue light.
And eliminate the glare coming
off all of those screens.
That means no more tire, dry
eyes, blurry vision or headaches.
Usually it seems like a hassle to have
to protect your eyes and that's why most
of us don't do it.
But Felix gray glasses aren't
like those weird computer glasses.
Um, you've seen before.
There's no yellow Lens Tint.
I don't even know what
the other ones look like.
Felix gray glasses are handcrafted
from premium Italian acetate,
Acetate Acetate,
so they won't make you look nerdy.
Acetate is the new fucking, I don't
know, raw material, whatever that is.
Is that buried between
limestone shale? Um, in fact,
throwing on some fee,
Felix Graze is an easy way to look.
Oh, pretty put together. Oh,
this stylish is what the Saint Felix
Gray glasses are available in non
prescription prescription and readers
with free shipping and free returns.
There's nothing to lose.
Don't go another day.
Looking at screens without the help
of Felix Graze. Go to Felix Gray.
glasses.com f e l I X.
G R A Y G l a s s e s d o t c o m s.
L a s H e. B u r. R to
protect your eyes today.
That's Felix Gray,
glasses.com/bar. Hi Felix.
Great glasses.com/ [inaudible]
a butcher box stowed.
Fucking get some meat kit.
Do you see those two fucking Boston guys
who claim that they have the divisional
red socks? Whatever, uh, banner.
I Dunno what's, they either stole that
fucking thing or that things fake.
Those things do not just fly off a fucking
stadium. I love how they will like,
you know, then whole thing sounded like
they act like they will, these good guys.
But the whole thing was like a ransom.
Like they had the fucking Lindbergh baby.
Hey, if you ever want to
fucking shady thing again.
Now they didn't even ask
for regular season tickets.
They asked for playoff fucking
tickets. Um, all right,
put your box. Do couple of shady
characters, but your box delivers healthy.
100% grass fed,
grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and
heritage bread, pork. Oh,
the greatest fucking fucking
animal you'll ever eat
is a blue blood. I don't want to be
fucking racist here against other pigs.
I don't want to be in the pigs,
a Ku Klux Klan. And by the way,
it is cool. It's not cool. I always
thought was Klu Klux Klan, Ku Klux Klan.
Um,
I don't want to be like the Grand Dragon.
It starts saying separate but
equal when it comes to pigs.
But there really is nothing like
a heritage bread. Pork. All right.
And it also,
it did come from Europe,
so this is sounding more
fucking pig racist as I go.
But I mean it's unbelievable. If you
haven't been listening to the podcast,
the heritage bread, pork, they can dre
sickly trace the bloodline of a pig.
There's actually people out
there that do that. Okay.
But if a woman
fucking shit on her,
um,
they trace the bloodline
of uh,
these God damn pigs,
pure bred pigs all the way
back to the original pigs
that came across the fucking Atlantic.
I don't know if they came across
with Christopher Columbus.
I Dunno if it was with the Nina,
the Pinta in the Santa Maria.
It wouldn't surprise me today if some
feminist group actually claimed that a
woman's sailed first
and and that nature
and wind in general is,
it's much harder for a woman
to sail than for a man.
I don't know what happened,
but these fucking pigs came over here
and evidently there was so god damn
delicious,
they did not let these pigs breed
with the pigs that were already here.
I don't know what. So whatever fucking
reason, these things, these are like,
you know, these are pure
bred, these, they're like the,
like the royal family of
Pigs, you know what I mean? So
they have this amazing bloodline, but
also there's a lot of interest breeding,
you know,
so that probably a little crazy.
But the thing is is when you get the
pork chop, it's dead so it can't get you.
So I recommend eating these
pigs do not have them as pets.
Okay.
Back to the copy.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets stats with a commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they murder them.
Each box comes with the least
eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual size meals.
Unless you're a fat fuck
or a competitive eater,
you can choose from five different
box types. All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Right?
I wonder if they let the
pure bred go in there. Well,
you should not be mixing the mate.
God made pork and he made me
and they're meant to be shepherd
Earl. You Lot the cross. All right.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
Personal experience.
I already told you it's the best God
damn pork chop I ever had ever except for
one restaurant. And that was
like some chef that was on TV,
but I made a pork chop
that would actually make,
I would say would make that chef
raised his eyebrow. Like, Hey,
that's not even close to what I made,
but I know you're proud of it.
Oh fuck you chef taking my knives and
I'm going home for $20 off your first box
in two pounds of free ground
beef and every box for,
for the life of your
subscription. Um, okay,
that's $20 off your first box and
two pounds of free meat a month.
And for that's a lot of fucking meat.
And for people who already
are butcher box subscribers,
you'll have a special deal on grumpy if
you can take advantage of by law logging
into your account.
Go to butcher box.com/burn into pro.
Enter the Promo Code [inaudible]
at checkout. Once again,
put your box.com/burr and enter
burr at checkout. All right,
heloc sleep.
He likes.
Okay.
There's nobody on the planet like you,
your age, 23 to 38. You're a millennial.
Why should you just have a
standard bed like generation y,
generation x baby boomers,
the greatest generation,
the lost generation,
the knickers generation.
Um, I said knickers, by the way, as
in pants before I get in trouble.
Sleep everybody.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
So why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everyone else?
Please mention the talking points
below. Of course I will. He likes sleep.
Hellings matches your body to the perfect
mattress so you get the best sleep of
your life. It doesn't matter if you
have back fat, if you have man tits,
if you have a crooked nose. Okay. I,
I'm guessing they pour you into some
sort of a mold or the boss loved of the
mattress molds to you.
It's like the dental impressions
I used to take back in the day,
except it's the mattress version.
They've developed nine
different mattresses tailored
to specific body types and
sleep preferences.
So evidently there's nobody like you
x till you get to that 10th person,
but still pretty cool though. You
know, just go to the Helix sleep,
alex.com/bird take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to the as
fucking hilarious,
which ways it hang and buddy and they'll
match you to a mattress that's perfect
for you. Contouring to your body
to provide unprecedented comfort,
better sleep. Do you have cankles? Yeah.
How would you describe your ass if
it was a balloon? Is it losing air?
Does it not happen?
Did somebody step on it?
36% of Helix sleep customers report
better sleep after switching to their
customized mattress from Helix Sleep Elyx.
Right now they're offering up
to $125 off all mattress orders.
Whether you're a side sweep up,
hot
sleeper,
Jesus Christ,
whether you're a thrasher,
whether you're trying to Kix, Kix,
Mac, whatever you got man, like a plush,
oh like a plusher affirm bread bed.
They've got their mattress
that will fit just right.
If you've got a body buried
in the back yard, you know,
you fucking think you know the tell tale
heart, they got that mattress for you.
Get up to Ah, to $25 off pealing
sleep.com/ [inaudible] Alex,
that's Helix Helix, sleep.com/bar
front and $25 off your mattress.
Order Helix,
sleep.com/ [inaudible] all right,
I believe that's all I have to read.
Um, oh, okay. I read,
I can't read all the right ones. Okay,
there you go. And I want to just tell,
I just want to thank all the brave
women out there who are podcasting.
I know it's so much more difficult for
you to turn on the power button than it
is for a man.
And I'm really looking at myself
right now and I'm reflecting on the,
the privilege that I've
enjoyed as a podcast or
yeah,
simply because of my genitalia.
Um,
today I will go out into the world
knowing that and adjusting my behavior
accordingly.
Women,
you have no work to do when it comes to
how you treat men just can just stay the
fucking course and uh,
keep telling everybody how difficult
you fucking lives are when there's like,
what, like six holidays a year. That
is specifically people valley. They
hype mother's Day versus Father's Day.
You know, there's all kinds of flowers,
candy get and show Ya,
right?
Father's Day, your dad, he's going
to die first. You know what I mean?
So this should be more of a sense of
urgency when you're thick da no. Yeah.
Get him a fucking tie.
What's,
he can fucking hang himself while he's
jerking off in the closet. All right.
That's,
that's the podcast,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
Got To make sure I said ladies first,
because they have, it's so much harder.
Everything, you know, just, just
them breathing is, you know,
air is more difficult on female
lungs. Um, and it's been proven.
Um, please enjoy this music and
then we're going to do a little, uh,
what do you call it? They're a little
fucking little throwback to the, uh,
to the blow back there to the law.
It's a Thursday afternoon podcast.
That'll be an extra half an hour of
greatest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Monday, just for Friday.
Monday morning podcast. That's what it is.
All right.
Have a wonderful weekend.
You cuts and go fuck yourselves
and I'll uh, talk to you on Monday.
Wait, he's tried to, you know, I know
it's going to be a tough weekend for you.
You know, my weekend's going to
be way easier to just, you know,
try to keep the heads trying
to keep your heads up.
[inaudible]
right off the bat. This sounds
fucking creepy to me. Video Doorbell.
Okay.
Uh, we'll insert dinging
sound. What does that mean?
I was supposed to fucking insert ding.
Dongs all right, let's do it again. Uh,
I can do this. Here we go. Door bell
sound.
This is like Donald Trump announcing
he's running for president doorbell sound
effect.
Yeah.
Did you meet doorbell? All
one word. Of course I did.
Let's see if I can do this correctly.
All right.
Hey everybody. Video
Doorbell. Let's do that again.
Oh, I'm mad. And all of
layers to the podcast
here. Hang on a second. It's got a
fucking, uh, it's gotta reload here.
Hey everybody. I'd like to take a
little bit of time to talk about
video doorbell. What is very odd.
I was the shit video doorbell.
This is the sound of a package
being delivered or friends
coming over for dinner,
but it's also the sound of something.
Plant someone planning to rob you.
Blind Jesus Christ. That
took a left turn, didn't it?
Over nine 95% of home break
ins happened during the day.
And I write,
but what is it?
What's going on here?
Oh,
I think I'm stuck on one of those youtube
loops where they just keep playing the
fucking the doorbell. Well, I
think it works with the copy.
I'm going to keep it anyways.
And burglars always almost always
start by ringing the doorbell to see if
someone's home before
pillaging your possession.
I guess that's a fancier doorbell.
Oh,
I like this music too
with ring video doorbell.
You can see and talk to anyone
from anywhere in the world
using your smart phone. Hi,
I'm bill her. What's
happening? Is this a DJ party?
MMM.
Okay. I think we're having
a fire alert here. Okay.
Back to the back to the copy rings.
Advanced motion detection alerts you,
even if someone doesn't ring the doorbell,
it's like a caller id for your home.
You know,
millions of people suffer every year
and they don't have a video doorbell.
Please share a personal story how this
could help you or someone you love. Hey,
will you share a fucking person
story of cons? Is Isn't enough?
I'm reading your copy. I
don't know anybody who has
a video of fucking doorbell.
How does that work for you as your story?
You'll get another one.
I'm sorry.
Instilling ring takes minutes and it
works with either your current wiring,
my built in rechargeable battery.
Put your mind at ease and protect your
home and your parakeet with the video
doorbell Time magazine named one
of the top 10 gadgets of 2014
Sheridan Kilmore porpoises.
Cause eventually you'd have to throw out
the wires and they will end up in the
ocean.
But right now my listeners get the
ring video doorbell for only $174.
That's $25 off the normal price.
Still kind of expensive though.
You know your fucking house comes
with the doorbell or he attached.
He's still making payments. Anyways, go to
ring.com/burnout protect your home
and@peaceofmindwithgotoring.com
slash burner
for $25 off.
Once again,
it's ring.com/book
oh and he fades up the music.
Jesus Christ. They could be a DJ,
but a fucking mouse had on me and see what
happens. I'll tell you what'll happen,
Huh? A bunch of drugs will be taken. Um,
how much can I freak out?
People at one of those raves.
If you just had the DJ and he's clean,
all this mellow shit,
then all of a sudden out of nowhere I
just started coming out on a mouse head
screaming to over and over again. I would
love to have an overhead shot of that,
you know,
maybe using one of those drones.
He just watched them all scattered like
fucking roaches all across the desert.
Stepping on sidewinders.
[inaudible]. Hey, what's up?
The one on it's built, right? It is
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September 20th,
2010 and I am doing this really late.
I apologize everybody.
I had a Baru till day.
I had a brutal Dan.
It had nothing to do with my patriots
getting their fucking asses handed to tool
by the Goddamn jets.
Congratulations.
All you green concept there in the
metal lands. Stick your chest out.
I'm sure you happy. I'm
sure you're proud. You know,
you know what sucks about it is the
jets game the week before the one that I
predicted that I was fucking dead on
right about that the ravens were gonna win
happened on a Monday night.
I had already recorded my podcast so I
didn't get to talk Shit and pat myself on
the fucking back about it.
By the time I did the jets bounce back
and kick the shit out of the Patriots and
a,
I will say this about it.
I actually recorded a podcast yesterday
before the jets game cause I wanted to
talk shit about it and give my prediction.
But um,
I actually ended up being
dead on in my own way,
but I didn't think anybody was
really going to believe it.
But then if some of them are
reminded me that I actually did call,
I said take the jets in the points.
I did a thing on versus network, uh,
this past week and I trashed the
jets as I always do because uh,
I'm from Boston and I fucking hate the
New York teams. I respect your city.
It's lovely,
especially in the fall,
walking through central park with the
leaves crunching under your shoes.
Who doesn't like to do that?
Wonderful, wonderful museums. You know,
a rare good slice of pizza.
I will tell you that only because New
Yorkers known for its pizza that are so
many fucking assholes who can't make
pizza have sprung up and they all say that
they're famous. I've said this shit
before just out of you know, any,
you New Yorkers want to tell
the tourists where to go.
Cause I got into a huge argument about
some fucking brought Eaton cunt from
Chicago who said New York pizza sucks.
I mean granted he enjoys their Lasagna,
whatever the fuck they called their pizza
out there. And if you're from Chicago,
tell me where to get the good deep dish.
Because the shit I get out there,
it's like even if you get
the personal size one,
it's like you feel like you ate a
birthday cake made out of spaghetti sauce,
but by the time you're done with it,
it's that level of full where you want
to kill yourself and it doesn't really
taste that good.
But I know there's no way that
there's not a great spot in Chicago.
So Chicago and New York have your pizza
war. Tell me where to go. But anyways,
um, this is what I felt about
the game was basically my heart.
I have to go with the Patriots,
but I just had that bad failing cause I
have this theory on divisional rivalries
is that they never go
the way they go back.
I remember the name of the God damn
show was on, on the versus networks.
That's really bad too because I had a
great time and they were like, yeah,
come back any time I can't remember the
name of the fucking show cause that's
how I operate.
I go in there totally in just
go in and fucking kill mode.
That sold to the point
that I don't even fucking,
I remembered the channel
that's new for me.
I just did a fuck load of media and had
something add something me the line in
it. I can't remember what
the Forza Nightline and, no,
it wasn't that. But uh, I was actually
right two fucking weeks in a row.
That's what's killing me now. This is
nobi breakdown the game. This is what, uh,
this is what I didn't like was the,
uh,
the Patriots' defense took a big step
backwards and they look like the hapless
crew from last fucking year.
But I'm also smart enough to realize
that week two does not define a fucking
season. But, uh, I gotta be honest.
Uh, and I was liking Hernandez.
That guy look great.
And I think Tom Brady was being
really generous when he said, Dad, uh,
we couldn't do anything right in
the second half. It's like, dude,
how about after the first quarter?
I mean,
I guess we went down and we
went up 14 fucking seven,
but then they march right back
down the field. But anyways,
hopefully I am,
I am converting some people to
my way of looking at sports,
which is last week doesn't mean shit.
I mean, you gotta, you gotta like
do like whatever the jets did,
either being anemic or kicking
the shit out of somebody.
You gotta do it like three, four weeks
in a row before you can get excited,
you know?
But I mean you just watched these analysts
on TV and it's like whatever somebody
just did is who the fuck they are.
And uh,
did I say it last week on the podcast,
how the paths that led
up three to 50 yards,
150 fucking yards to osho say
I didn't like those numbers.
I did not like those numbers.
I still,
I thought it was going to be one
of those cunty 19 to 17 games.
And I thought in the end I was praying
that we were going to come out and get a
victory, but I did not, I did not
think that we were going to get,
we were going to get pounded and we got,
we got pounded in a very light way.
I don't remember any sort of big hit
other than the big hit in the end for the
fumble.
But it was just sort of,
I just felt like we were in a prevent
defense from the second quarter on,
you know, ah, just, you know, you
deal with that zone, let people go.
And I have to admit that fucking
Reavis guy really pissed me off when
he got burned for a touchdown and then
grabs his Hami.
Can I do that from now on?
When I fuck up in life and I'm sitting
there talking all kinds of shit and I'm
killing for 20 minutes with jokes.
And then I tell one that
bombs and then I just,
I started grabbing my hamstring
and I fucking, you know,
lay down and have somebody stretch it out.
That was a really fucking bitch move.
And I don't buy it.
I don't buy the whole goddamn story.
I don't like how before
the game even started,
reverse already had a fucking excuse. I
think he was scared from the week before.
Not that he's bad,
the guys to ship,
but I think he was out of shape and he
was worried that a Randy Moss was gonna
run all over his island.
That's so fucking gave Reavis island,
you know,
who would ever go there,
but you're fucking guys
standing around squatting down
and that quarterback fucking position,
you know,
I don't know. Speaking
of that. Speaking of gay,
here's an email I got recently from
a gay guy. Uh, believe it or not,
I have,
I have all kinds of fans on this.
You wouldn't know this from some of
those fucking assholes up in Seattle who
branded me a homophobe because they
listened to the first half of the,
what are you a fig bit in?
Stomped off like the fucking
pansies that they were.
Here's a guy right here now.
All right. Said Bill, watch,
let it go last night. Uh, and it
was fantastic. Congratulations.
Uh, that's hilarious. Um, no, you know
what's hilarious was I was thinking,
let it go as my last special
and I fly to held it in my head.
I immediately pictured my, uh, why
do I do this anyway? So I'm an idiot.
Let me start over. Watch, let it go last
night. It was fantastic. Congratulations.
It was kind of cool to hear some of
the things you had talked about on the
podcast turned into developed bits.
I was wondering if you brought stuff from
the stage to the podcast or is it vice
versa?
Do you use the podcast to develop bits?
I was also wondering how much input,
uh,
you are other comics have on editing
on the editing of your specials.
I've noticed that your recent special is
lit differently. Better in my opinion,
than many comedy central specials.
The audience is dark in there is a nice
spotlight on you instead of the whole
stage being lit. How did
you get that deal? Also,
the commercial breaks seem
to come at strange places.
Did you get to decide where they went?
Sorry for all the questions.
Bottom line is the special.
It was amazing.
The podcast is great and I'm a huge fan.
Well, thank you very much that he said,
ps, she looked great and
better and better as you age.
Does that seem gay for one man to say to
another? Well guess what bill? I am gay.
Deal with it. Ah, that's
fucking awesome. All right,
great questions. They're
twinkle toes. All right.
What do we got here? The first one
he asked, he said a watch, let it go.
Less than it was for to Dah, Dah, Dah. Oh,
you're wondering if do I take stuff from
the podcast and take it to the stage
and vice versa? Ah, there's
a little bit of both,
but definitely more podcasts to the stage.
I try not to burn bits on the podcast
where it's like if I actually did a bit
from my act, then you come and see me.
It's already kind of a finish thing,
then I would feel like
I was fucking you over.
But there's definitely times when I riff
on stuff that a little light goes off
on my head and I'm like, you
know what? That's really funny.
And I think that I could take
that somewhere. But even then,
even if you heard it
on the podcast, it, it,
I don't say it the way I set it
on the podcast, it like continues,
you know what I mean?
Kind of like when Stevie Ray Vaughn did
his cover of a say what Jimmy Hendricks,
which was, wasn't that like
two things spliced it together.
I can't remember. Was that rainy
day? I can't remember. He did.
He did a cover up and he just
sort of took the beginning riff.
That's right. Yeah. He took the beginning,
refer that and then he just sort of
fleshed out the middle and edit his whole
type of shit to it.
So I tried to do that with like,
did I just bring up Stevie Ray Vaughn
and Jimmy Hendricks? I'm sorry. Sorry.
My fucking Egos really pumped up with
all the great emails you guys sent me
about my special last night. But
yes, to answer your question, um,
occasionally shit like
that does go to the stage,
but I'm really sensitive about
that because I don't like people,
I wouldn't want someone to come
to me and be like, dude, it was,
it was everything you said
on the podcast. I, you know,
I don't mind if somebody
comes up and says, yeah,
that was something I heard in the podcast
and then you took it in this other
area. Like, listen, I'm just
fucking meandering right now.
You can't do that on understand upstairs.
People will be throwing like
fucking potato skins at me. So, um,
that's the deal. And if ever do an old
bit from my act, I actually just say it.
This is a bit I used to do and I usually
do an abridged version. So there we go.
All right, next one. Ah, I was also
wondering how much input you had, uh,
on the editing of your specials.
Um,
that's a huge thing that I have input on
and from why do I do this and let it go
is there is a specific look that I want
and as specific vibe that I am looking
for and that,
and it's very important to me and I
think it's even more important than the
fucking material if you can believe it.
Just because I have seen some unbelievable
comedians with shitty production and
it knocks down the level
of your performance.
And that sucks because
it's not your fault.
So you really have to like,
I've learned that just through like
the few TV movie things that I've done,
like as far as editing, lighting,
all those fucking guys, the sound,
all of those guys,
director, all of those guys.
It's like they can take a mediocre
performance and make it look fucking
unbelievable and they can take an,
an amazing performance and make it look
like cannonball run part two if they
don't know what the fuck they're
doing. So, uh, so there you go.
There's my big shoutout to
art and industry who's done
my last two specials and
we'll continue doing my specials
cause they do a great fucking job. Uh,
I basically tell them exactly what I'm
looking for and I always come at him with
shit that has nothing to do with comedy.
They'll just be like,
what do you want it to look like?
I'm like,
you ever see the magnificent seven when
they're fucking sitting there eating
those Rancharrah Huevos whatever
the fuck you saying. Um,
I come at him like that.
Um, so there you go. Great.
Kept great question right out of
the Goddamn Gate. Um, but anyways,
let's continue on. Uh, talking
a little football here.
Um, how about those fucking bears? Huh?
I didn't know that Mike Martz is,
uh,
is their offensive coordinator.
They all of a sudden overnight got
a little scary. And like I said,
I'm not judging them on two weeks.
I mean they've basically lost to the
fucking lines and then we're given that
victory. My apology to lions fans
last week cause I was going like,
look at you guys,
you're playing competitive.
I had not seen the highlight of how
you got fucked out of that game. Um,
but like that is a devastating combination
cause Mike Martz is PR is like right
in his fucking wheel wheel house.
You know what I mean?
It's like how Deniro was doing comedy
and meet the parents and all that shit.
But all of a sudden if, if they go back
to doing the good fellas shit, he's right.
He's debts.
He's fucking in it.
So
yeah,
I dunno man. That's, that's,
that's the big thing.
You got to have all the fucking pieces.
You could have the ownership,
you have to have the coaches and
you have to have the players.
It's like what that fucking Matt Cassel.
I remember Bob,
my buddy of mine was giving me Shit when
we traded him for a first round fucking
draft pick or whatever, the chiefs, he
was like, dude, I mean the guy look it up.
He went 11 and five and then all of this
fucking pieces,
all those people who are trying to give
Brady Shit because Brady was hurt yet
the patriots when 11 and five typical
fantasy football fucking morons,
they don't realize that Mac castle
was driving a Lamborghini that year.
He was driving a team throughout the
regular season that went 16 and oh when
every fucking game and what did he,
he managed the fucking game and
gave us five less fucking victories,
but then people's heads, they're like
11 and five man, that's fucking nuts.
If he goes to Kansas City
and does what it does, what
drives that fucking 1972 eco liner that
is the Kansas City chiefs now all of a
sudden, right? You
fucking need a fuel pump.
The time and belt snaps and right there.
Matt Cassel looks like he should be
holding a fucking clipboard again.
Is it his fault? I don't fucking think
so. But you got to have everybody.
So that's my point. Dot. The
fucking Chicago bears haven't.
Yeah.
What's his face, Mike? March. Whenever
the hell his God damn name is.
I can't even think at this point.
I'm so sick of fucking talking
after a week of press last week. Um,
yeah,
having those two guys is huge,
is fucking huge.
And all of a sudden Jay Cutler looks like
a good Goddamn quarterback, doesn't he?
Doesn't he?
So with that, how about some
predictions? I gotta Talk Shit early.
Pets are playing again next Sunday.
Which Patriot team is going to show up,
you know,
according to in your my stats,
the exact same fucking defense
showed up both fucking weeks.
God dammit.
Our defense stinks.
We're not going to win shit without,
you know, something that's actually a
great, uh, I think it,
cause I never felt like the patriots
players ever got their fucking do when we
are winning those champions. Yet there
were a mediocre team with no superstars.
Now all of a sudden I don't,
you look at Teddy Bruschi in verbal and
all those guys in a different light.
Maybe you don't, I don't fucking know.
What do we got? Let me talk one thing.
New Orleans at San Francisco,
there's another divisional rivalry game.
I don't like it. Everybody say New
Orleans is going to run all over them.
I don't like it.
I think it's going to be closer than
that just because they were in the same
fucking division. Those games
are always conti. All right.
Week three buffalo at New England.
Yeah.
Joe G H I want to,
we're going to bounce back,
but I mean I don't find them
fucking know what that difference.
You know what it is about the pets.
We have no pass rush. All right.
Jet Fans before you get all excited about
Sanchez sitting back in a fucking lazy
boy in the pocket. That son of a bitch
can scramble though. I will give you that.
But who do the jet have next week?
Who Do they get? Who they get?
Are you guys talking shit
again? Oh, jetset Miami.
Miami's going to beat Ya, man.
He's got a fucking insane defense. You're
going to go on the road. All right.
I think. What's his face? Rex? Ryan's
going to poke his head out of the shelf.
He's going to start talking shit.
It's going to look at,
get a little drunk and get sunburned.
Fall Asleep on the fucking beach is
he's going to be miserable down
there. I have no idea. I have no idea.
But I'm telling you right now,
they are fucking jet fans before your
hoist a fireman up on your shoulder like
you're doing the village people
fucking act. Uh, don't sleep on Miami.
You don't like about Miami.
Their coach looks like he's in the
fucking witness protection program.
The fuck is with that guy.
I watched that game and,
and they kept cutting to
him on the sidelines on,
I have no fucking idea what he looks like.
He's got a baseball hat yanked down to
his huge fucking Tony Curtis sunglasses.
He's got that big, uh, who's
that guy from the big Lebowski?
Ah, does the narration, whatever the guy
from mass, he's got one of those fucking,
I own a Harley musty.
I have no fucking idea what he looks like.
And then Green Bay. It's Chicago. That's
a great Monday night game. All right, Jay,
I have to get back to the podcast here
because I know a lot of people are,
are uh, not sports fans. So
let me tell you about my week.
Everybody, um, leading
up to my specialist,
I went to New York City and I did the
opiod Anthony Program. Wonderful Program.
If for some reason you live in a cave
and you've never heard of it, it's a,
a sort of a political show. Um, a lot
of topics are discussed. I'm actually,
obviously I'm fucking around over
the top and I got to tell you,
Jim Norton had the funniest God damn joke
that I don't even think got the laugh
it deserved.
It was so funny.
It actually made me a better person and
I'm going to tell you why I was fucking
opiate mentioned he was trying to sign
something and he said that they wouldn't
let him sign it with like a pen to paper.
He had to do this virtual signing
or whatever. That's computer thing.
So me being the shed head
than I am immediately jump
into a connecting the dots
that this is this big conspiracy that
they want to have this computer. Um,
I dunno. Something like, I
don't know. I can't see, I'm
so stupid. I can't even see,
I can't even say how the fuck am I
trying to say here. They basically,
then they have [inaudible],
they have you basically your
signature like on a stamp,
but it's in like computer form and
they go and that's for the Illuminati.
And then later on five years,
if you don't like what they're doing,
just take out the Amaa
Nazi document and it just puts your
computer signature right underneath it.
That's what they're going to do.
And then Jim just goes,
or the Illuminati could
just forge your signature.
Uh, I butchered it was fucking great.
And it really just made me feel like,
exactly bill. Exactly. You know,
why don't you just fucking relax
if they're really that powerful,
do they really need to create
schemes to that fucking level?
And a, I have to tell you, I,
I must've thought about that
line maybe 50 fucking times.
I've just been walking around thinking
my crazy thoughts and then that joke,
his voice keeps popping in my head going,
oh,
the Illuminati could
just forge a signature.
And it just makes me laugh at what a
fucking ridiculous human, yeah. Human
being. I am. Um, so there you go.
Shout out to Jimmy Norton now. Um,
but anyways, so this is my week. So I
did the opening of the program. I did a,
I did the versus network.
Had a great time on that and hopefully
we'll be doing more shit on that.
I also did a Nesson where I talked
to all kinds of shit about the jets.
I had fun on that one because that
was just in Boston. So I was able to,
I didn't have to bleep be diplomatic
on that one and a what others did.
Pete Dominick show,
I did a Jim Breuer show.
All those guys just want to thank say
thank you to everybody who let me run my
mouth and a height,
my special and thanks everybody
who watched it and uh,
sent me all the great emails and
everything. And uh, and with that,
if you'd like to buy it, go to amazon.com
you can actually, the presale I think,
is it still a presale price?
I Dunno, it was like 13, 26.
Uh, if you want to buy it for that cheap
amount and then bring it to one of my
shows, I'll fucking sign it
for you. I don't give a shit.
Just go ahead and buy it.
And I would really appreciate it if you
guys would go out and buy it because
believe it or not,
it really does help me as a
performer if you do things like that.
And uh,
one of the things I've noticed
being a huge music fan is I go on,
um, I go on youtube and I'm
always watching, uh, you know,
like clips of bands and shit like that.
And one of the things that people keep
asking is they say where resolved the
talent. You know what I mean? Like where
are the Beatles were the stones where,
where are the, uh, the Marvin Gaye's
where all these fucking people,
and I have this theory,
granted Jim Norton might take the fucking
piss out of this one too with one of
his fucking life,
great lines,
but it's the same people asking these
questions of the people not paying for
music and a decade of trying
to have your cake and eat it.
Basically the music industry
doesn't exist anymore.
And for his dirty and filthy
as those sons of bitches were,
there were just like,
there's good and bad comics.
There were genius guys in that industry
and they knew they could spot talent and
they knew how to develop it and nurture
it before they put it out there and that
type of stuff. And then of course
then they would steal from them. Um,
but like that system doesn't
fucking exist anymore. And,
uh, my business, it's going
the same route where TV, film,
Dvds and all those are
not being paid for and uh,
people are losing their
jobs and that type of shit.
So I don't know if you like comedy,
if you like good television,
I suggest trying to not saying
don't watch reality shows.
I would be fucking hypocrite right
now cause I love the Jersey shore.
I really haven't watched season
too,
but I watched the Jersey shore,
but like I still try to
watch scripted shows.
I pay for movies, I don't steal
movies. I pay for all my fucking music.
And uh, I don't know. If
you don't give a fuck,
then just by all means go
ahead and steal it. But if,
if you're one of those
people who's wondering yeah,
where all the great bands are,
where the great writers are, Eh,
that they don't have
jobs right now,
they don't because you can sit on
a toilet and take a shit going,
sitting on a toilet,
sitting on the toilet.
You can do that and you'll get for some
reason a zillion fucking hits. And uh,
I dunno, I don't even know what my fucking
point is. Just for the love of God.
Can you buy the Goddamn DVD?
All right.
$13 26 cents so he can pick it up.
Fucking 20 bucks at one of my shows.
I'll sign it for you. Take a
picture, give you a Goddamn hug,
whatever the fuck you need. But for
Christ's second, can you support my God,
they have career. That's all
I'm asking you. All right, look,
I go on youtube too. All right.
I'm just, I'm not saying, you know,
I mean, I go there, I look at Shit
and I'm looking at Shit for free.
I realize that, but the shit that
I really like, I do pay for it,
but I pay for all my fucking music.
All right.
God dammit.
You know what's funny is most of you are
probably going to go out and buy my DVD
and I just basically did what the fucking
Catholic priests would do when I was
growing up or they would basically yell
at the people who showed up for church.
So with that,
let's give you some funny youtube clips
and you can watch all of these right in
a row. Conveniently on the, uh,
the EMN podcast.com the official fan
page of the Monday morning podcast.
And I want to thank all the
listeners, uh, who go on to that left,
all those great messages about them going
out there, trying to get the word out.
I'm telling you, even though
you know it, it helps out.
You have no fucking idea how much that
helps me out due to the fact that there's
500 channels now. There's the
internet, there's video games,
there's people with cameras
making videos for fucking youtube.
There's just so much shit out there.
There's Tivo and all that like you guys
do in. That really, really helped me.
So I just want to say thank you. Okay.
This is really a feel good podcast.
You would never know that my team got
trounced by the team that I've been
trashing. Oh, by the way.
Oh, the Jetson apology. Um,
I'm not the part where I say they're
not going to win the super bowl and I,
I won't apologize for
that. After week two, um,
but the fact that I actually suggested
that they still play a giant stadium and
that they sub leaded their
stadium from, uh, from the giants.
They don't now,
now they co own it with the giants.
So the jet's got a little more credibility
in the giants became a little more
pathetic,
but they can spin it and just say that
what they're doing is a very green thing
to do. It's great for the environment.
But, but considering, uh, the jets,
their colors are green,
I still think that they come out on top.
So a what do you guys say about that?
Um,
I missed the game last night where
Peyton beat the shit out of his little
brother.
Like all big brothers should do.
I have to tell you that if
you have a younger brother,
at no point in your life can you
ever lose to him in anything ever.
Yeah.
Now I, you know, he can
get a better fucking job,
marry a hotter woman
that can fucking happen.
But I'm talking about shit
that really counts like sports,
wrestling and a,
in a real fight you can never
fucking loose. And if they,
even if he beats you in a fight,
what you do is you just turn that into
a round and as you collect yourself,
you grabbed something to beat them over
the head with and then you went round to
, I know the ladies out there
probably don't understand that,
but anybody with a younger brother,
I'm telling you,
I never lost to any of
my younger brothers.
I am undefeated in fights undefeated.
If I said that right now,
considering we're all about the same size,
I would have a couple of
fights on my card, but, uh,
hopefully no one in my family
listens to this. All right,
let's get onto the youtube videos for
the week. All right. Your sons a bitches.
Um, all of these are available
on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
You can watch them right in a row.
All right.
This is one of my favorite videos I've
seen in awhile. It's called Macho Salad,
m a c h o o Macho Salad.
And this is just a great
piece of acting from a,
I don't know what movie this is.
I believe at they speaking German.
I can't fuck I remember,
but this guy wants to get laid and his,
his girl tells him, you
know, she's not in the mood.
This is what I'm guessing from the
dialogue and tells him to go make a salad.
And this son of a bitch makes a
fucking salad and a, it's awesome.
It's just like,
it's just one of those things where I
don't know how many takes this guy had to
do, but, uh, it's,
it's the shit and I aspire to someday be
able to do something like that. Acting.
All right. Um, the next
thing we got here, uh,
this,
this video actually made me so upset.
You have a watch a youtube video and you
wish that you could just somehow step
into your screen and fucking go into the
video and just basically inflict your
view of what the justice should
have been now. Well, okay.
The watch this video, it's actually a
clip from the doctor Phil Show. You know,
that crooked cop looking dude
who pretends he's a psychologist,
but he's really just a fucking therapist
who wanted to have groupies so we can
get some more pussy on the
side and realized that he
wasn't going to get it in a
, in a fucking therapy room.
So he was like, I know,
I'll do a TV show and
say obvious shit slowly.
Uh, anyways, let's continue. Uh,
he has a clip on there.
It's the name of this video
is called fat kid slaps mum.
Mum.
All right and just to set this one up,
this is basically obviously a
mother who can't control her kid.
He's a fat kid.
He's about 11 or 12 is voice hasn't
changed yet and he's sitting there sitting
down across from his mother who is
also sitting down and nose to nose.
They are having discussion and this
kid is taking his mother to task,
interrupting her and then when she
gives him shit for interrupting her,
he goes, well how does that feel?
How does that, how do you like it?
Like completely out of fucking control
and this kid's got this temporary so
fucking out of line.
And then she starts giving them shit
and out of nowhere he just hauls off and
fucking slaps her like a God damn pimp.
Oh you only need one.
The only reason why I wasn't a pimp slap
it cause it wasn't a backhand but it
had the same fucking,
it sounded like a flare chop
right to her fucking cheek.
And there's this pause and I'm like,
oh my God,
she is going to be on him like a mountain
lion and I'm going to see the bomb.
My guy jumping in trying to pull her off
from climbing the eyes out of this kids
fucking head. There's that pies.
And then the kid just goes,
how does that feel?
How do you like it?
And the mother does absolutely nothing.
And I swear to God,
I was just like,
I had to like stand up and like walk
around and do like little circles.
You don't when you want to
walk away from the video,
but you have to watch it again.
So you just do those little
fucking figure eights. I was like,
you gotta you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Why aren't you fucking chill
in that kid right now? Right.
And I, you know what I would've
done if I was there, if I was at a,
I just wanted to insert, I just really,
I was scaring my dog over there. Sorry,
Dude. Sorry about that. All right. We're
just acting over here. Everything's good,
man.
Everything's good.
Cleo Odey Odey Odo
sorry.
Um,
what does it take to make it
dogs fucking wag its tail?
It takes literally two
seconds. Um, anyways,
I just looked at that video and I was,
yeah,
I immediately just imagine
being married to that woman.
And then that was my son and I was,
yeah,
I got to tell you right now,
if,
you know,
when I married here and we
have kids and do all that shit,
if one of our kids ever slaps
her in the face, I will.
I would've, yeah, I would
have fucking throat.
I want to choke slam that kid through
the fucking coffee table with any luck.
It would be one of those old school
and tea coffee tables, you know,
that were made out of the really good
wood from deep in the fucking forest,
not that Ikea Shit that explodes
like a fucking stunt table, you know?
And I would just put that motherfucker
right through it and then I would pull
him up by his goddamn larynx and then
right through the fucking dry wall.
All right. My hand would be
disappearing into the wall.
Like I just fist it a fucking horse.
And you would be wondering
where that kid was.
And then I pull him out and he'd have
all that fucking plaster in his hair and
he'd start to cry and then I would just
fucking take away like three quarters of
his oxygen and I would whisper
in his ear really calmly,
like one of those bad guys in those great
eighties movies with Mel Gibson. Well,
once they get them tied up
or fucking Stallone or whatever,
all the fucking, the goons would get and
tied up. And then the, the, the real, the,
the head bad guy who is running shit
would just come in all relaxed with his
fucking dress shoes and suit and we'll
just come up and just sort of put his
face like parallel to the
other dude's face. You know,
you just come in and he just whispered
right in the guys here, nice and calmly.
That's what I would do to him as
this kid was struggling to breathe.
I just put my fucking head right next
to his ear and I would just be like,
if you ever slap your
mother in the face again,
I will fucking kill you.
Do you understand me?
Do you want to stay on me?
Yeah.
The only reason why you're not dead right
now is because I haven't figured out
how to get away with it yet.
I'd be saying Shit like that and then you
go upstairs and you go to your fucking
room. If you even look at her over
the next month, I swear to God,
I will grab you by your fucking baby
fat and the top of your fucking head.
I will throw you upside down
through the fucking bay window.
Do you understand that?
As you sit out there in the rain,
picking the glass in the woods,
shards out of your body?
I'm going to take a tray or hot macaroni
and throw it right on your fucking face.
That's what I'm going to do. If you
ever fucking touch your mother again,
was that a little too violent? Was it
will I don't give a fuck. All right.
That's how I came up. You
know, I grew up, if I,
if I actually the reason why I expected
that woman to claw their kid's eyes out,
cause that's where my mom would have done.
My mom did not need a father figure
hanging around the Goddamn
House. Basically. If,
if that woman was my mother,
the only role the dad would have would
be at some point to pull the mom off that
kid in order to fucking say, my mother
would have just grabbed the nearest,
she would have fucked it off. Remember
old school moms, they, they've drew blood,
they will like cats and they just fucking
does is dug their nails into you and
they grabbed you in really weird places.
They would just grab like a handful of
neck somehow have your juggler in their
head.
They do that and then the other hand,
like their thumb would somehow get into
this part of your arm pit you didn't
even know existed and they would just
take a chunk of flesh out of that somehow
there'd be no holes in your fucking tee
shirt and they would just stay with it
was unbelievable.
It's like a fucking Scifi movie.
When you were done and you,
you fucking went upstairs and your skin
was just burning from wherever the fuck
they had Claude you when
you took it look like, yeah,
like he got attacked by a bobcat
right to delos mom's exist anymore.
I Dunno. I think there's been
an overcorrection and more time.
One of my brothers said that I kicked
him in the face, which was bullshit.
I kicked him in the stomach,
which was considered legal and
working it out amongst yourselves.
My mother was brushing her hair.
She was late for work. She had to,
she had to go with frontier justice.
She didn't have time for
my side of the story.
She just turned around and she went
to smash this thing over my head,
like a fucking gavel. So I did. Basically,
I did this defensive move where I ducked,
but not like a man.
I didn't do like the boxing,
like fucking come up and under and
then fucking with the right hook.
I didn't do that shit.
What I basically did was I immediately
did a fucking one 80 so now I wasn't
facing my mother.
I put my shoulders up to my ears,
I bent over slightly at a 45 degree
angle and then for some reason I made my
arms go a little,
my elbows go a little past my back and I,
I I squinted eye look like
Pau Gasol before right before
he decides to go to the
rack, anticipating the foul.
And Luckily I ducked enough,
she missed my head and just
hit me right in the back.
Like I took one of those folding chairs
and rustling from Pat Patterson right to
my fucking back and I went down and a
Goddamn heap in landed on that Kmart
fucking bath mat is the shards of the
plastic brush just landed all around me.
And you know what my mother's big
concern was was that she broke her brush,
you know,
and it was old school back then moon.
You didn't have flat screen TVs and
when you're broke a brush, if they,
if the rubber part with the bristles
still existed, she just continue using it.
And she did for years.
She just,
she just hit rather than having
a handle and fucking combing it,
like brushing it like Barbie,
she just held it in her hand now like you
know those brushes black guys use when
they try to get waves in their hair.
That's what it looked like and she just
kept using that and every time I sought
arrows reminded of that and it was
like a week later that the two of us,
we just started laughing about it like,
mom,
when are you going to buy a new brush?
And she's one,
there's nothing wrong with this one.
There's nothing wrong with it.
It doesn't fucking three quarters
of it doesn't even exist anymore.
It isn't a fucking reminder that you
smash the rest of it over it over one of
your kids' backs.
No,
she didn't give a fuck and she should
enough. She was right. She was right.
That was my thing about that show it.
I don't know.
That's the way parenting used to be.
The mom used to kick the shit out of
you and the dad didn't have to kick the
shit out of you.
All he had to do is go and you
fucking peed yourself a little bit.
And that was it. So that's what
I got out of that clip, man.
That's just bad parenting. That kid
should have never got it. That was my kid.
That kid would have been stuffed upside
down in a fucking hamper and slid down a
flight of fucking stairs.
Huh? How about that?
How about your point now? How
does that feel? All right.
Give him a Lo's ass kickings where you,
you only end up with one shoe on.
You know,
I used to do a bit about that on stage.
I don't know if I ever fucking, uh,
I might have to bring that one back.
Speaking of that first
question that I had,
I used to do a bit about anytime you
get beat up by five or more people,
you always lose a shoe. You know,
what the hell bit was that like,
you know,
you get your ass kicking your ass
kicked when there's like debris of you
afterwards and you have to like
collect your personal belongings.
Oh fuck. I remember. What the
hell did the hell did it go?
Some other tag was something about having
a deck of cards. I had a decade cave.
You see the jacket diamonds, like just
your shit was just that. I don't know.
I can't remember how the fuck
it went. But anyways. Um,
so if you want to see what old
school parenting looks like it,
but in a funnier way, there's another
youtube clip. Watch this, this clip.
It's called spoiled kid
gets yelled at and uh,
yeah, the guy yelling in. This
is basically dad. All right.
This is the funny version of it,
of what he really had to do
and was totally in the right.
Um, when he did it, like I don't have
any, uh, that's my thing. You know what?
The old school parenting, you
know, it bothered me as a kid,
but when I look back on it now,
it's like I deserved so many ass.
Kickings so many fucking ass kick.
I deserved them.
I fucking deserve to ever, what time,
what are my brother's pissed me off.
And I took out a garden hose and I started
spraying it through the fucking, uh,
I was so mad cause I had a water,
the plants and he was making fun of me
and I just took this thing and I fucking,
I just, I, I, you know, I had a
temper, I just sprayed it right at him,
right into the house. And uh, you know,
and that was the day I
learned what dark tastes like.
Yeah.
My mother had me, was on my back
just pushing me into the mud.
Ah Yeah. That was, those were the days.
And then all your other siblings would
stand around laughing cause your mother
couldn't hear the laughter over the rage.
She always focus on the one part is
we're just laughing and then you come in
with your mud covered face
crying and everybody just laughs.
Just Ah, Shit. I used to see,
I remember back in the day,
I remember seeing one of my, one of
my friends mouthed off to his mother,
I went over to his house to get some
lunch and he mouthed off to his mom
and he wanted to see when it dessert
or something and she was just like, no,
it's lunchtime. You don't get any dessert.
And he can just go. So mom, I hate you.
Like we were little kids and the kids'
Dad did not even look up from his
sandwich.
Just took a whole Glick kids,
whole glass of milk and
just threw it in my face.
So my friend just starts crying,
right?
The Dad goes back to eating a sandwich
and then the mother just got up right on
cue, went over and just
cleaned it up and that was it.
And I can guarantee you that kid
never said, oh mom, I hate you again.
This whole fucking time out shit.
I know that's a hacky bit,
but I really believe it. I
really believe that. You know,
you got to slap them around. You gotta
you gotta you know gotta hit you.
I had a really hard, I'm not talking
about literally abusing them, but yeah,
you gotta throw a glass of milk
in their face. You gotta grow,
you gotta basically ruined
one of their shirts.
And by that I mean grabbed them by the
front of it and lift them up by it to the
point where all their body weight is
on the neck of the shirt and it rips a
little bit and leaves that red mark that
goes past your fucking collarbone down
to your sternum. Then there's a whole
generation of kids, listen to this day,
have no idea what I'm talking about.
But anybody remotely my age is punching
the dashboard right now. Laughing,
remembering all of this
shit. Uh, I don't know.
Did it make us better people?
I don't fucking know,
but we shut the fuck up at dinner.
All right, let's continue. Um,
question, uh, Bill, would you
ever consider hosting a late
night talk show? I would,
I think I would love to do that.
Um,
I would love to do that.
Provided I could do my monologue,
like my stand up and I could really just
sort of a do what I do in a cleaner,
cleaner way. I guess. I would
love to do that. And uh,
I think I could actually ask some
really interesting questions.
Um, you know, and I'm not going to
give away what the fucking questions.
I'm talking a little shit.
Got a little Rex Ryan on you here.
Go Little Rex Ryan on you
here. Um, yeah, I would love,
I would love doing that, but,
um, I, my career has not
gone down that direction.
So that's like a whole thing where I
think you have to decide you want to be a
broadcaster.
Um,
like Jon Stewart,
like early on,
like I remember hearing like he just
was this phenomenal comedian and then he
just really early on started going down
that road of being a broadcaster and you
get seen as that. So,
uh, I dunno, who knows.
Never say never.
If they gave me the opportunity now
with fucking take it in a second.
I would take it in a fucking
second. Um, all right,
here's some advice. All right. Uh, but,
but uh, but, but uh, all right, Bill,
let me paint me this picture for a moment.
I used to be terrible with girls.
I was always a nice guy, but that
gets you nowhere. Oh, Jesus. Exactly.
Girls always said I was really nice,
but uh, they were never interested.
This was because I lacked confidence
and wasn't sure of myself.
There you go there. This
guy taken responsibility for
himself. It's exactly yet,
so as time went on,
I got a few practice girls
in my conference inevitably
grow and I started doing
well. There you go right there. All
you youngsters, young guys out there.
Nice guys trying to get fucking laid.
There it is. That's page one right there.
You're a nice guy. You're
fucking boring them. All right.
You gotta be a little bit
of a Dick, right? Nia is,
you walk in and try to have
respect for the podcast.
How much look at you. I can see
it on your face right now. These,
she's doing that classic girl thing
where she's trying not to smile and she's
rolling her fucking eyes and you know it.
You gotta be a little bit of a cocky
asshole. You've got to come up.
You've got insult them a little bit.
Yeah, you do. Like if I saw you right now,
even though I like your outfit, I would
walk up to you and be like, what do you,
what'd you come straight from?
Work.
That's how you dress when you
come out and you'd be like, what?
I'm just fucking with you. What are
you drinking right out of the gate?
Come right out. Put your balls right on
the fucking table. Take a look at him,
sweetie.
I'm just trying to grow.
Shout No. Whenever you got to
charmer, do what you gotta do.
I don't like your fucking sandals.
I don't like them.
I've been meaning to tell you. Oh, that
was a good one. Right in the fucking leg.
Didn't see that. She just gave me the
finger as she walked out. See right there.
That's the little ebb and flow.
You have to have in your relationship.
See if you're always complimenting them.
You know what women are like,
they're like dogs,
right?
This is a record for me. I've gone 46
minutes without trashing women. Um, yeah,
they like dogs. They really are. As
much as they tried to say, we like dogs,
people are just like fucking dog. She
can't reward them all the Goddamn time.
Stroke in the back of that Goddamn head.
Next thing you know,
there's shitting on the rug.
Maybe once in a while.
I got to give him a little discipline.
Tell him you don't like what they're
wearing. Um, anyways, so he was a guy.
He figured it out. Why am I not
getting laid? I don't have confidence.
So what do I need to do? I need to
go out there and get some at bats.
That's what you'd do.
You'd go out there and you start talking
some shit and you're going to bomb and
you're gonna embarrass yourself,
but eventually you're going
to push through and all
those times you embarrassed
yourself. They're just, they're just
going to become, they're just gonna.
They're just gonna be
funny stories to tell. Um,
oh shit.
Do I have a funny one?
I remember when I used to
try and go to dance clubs,
which were totally weren't my saint,
cause not only was I not good
looking enough to be in there,
I didn't know how to
dance and couldn't dance.
And I would just walk up to girls and
my opening line was I would yell, Hey,
do you want to dance? And
then they would go, no.
And then I walk away.
Oh.
And it would take me at least another 40
minutes if I did to get the courage to
approach another one. And that's the thing
you brought. Still fucking appreciate.
You know, what are you going to do? Well,
you got to sit there and pluck you who
has and pick the right fucking colored
dog, make sure it matches your bra.
You get to do all of that and private.
We got to sit there and basically
it's like doing stand up.
The only way to learn how to do is you
have to go on stage and just eat your
balls. You got to bomb. Um, I dunno.
I guess it all gets made up because they
get pregnant and they got to deal with
that fucking Shit, you know? And if
forget about the pain of pregnancy,
can you imagine another thing
growing inside of you? Jesus.
I would go to the doctor and be
like, get this out of me. This,
this virus that can fit.
It's eating my guts.
No, no, no, no. That's what's supposed
to happen. Get it out. Get it out.
Um, all right. Anyways,
let's continue here.
So a time went on and I realized
how ignorant all that's.
That was all right ladies.
Ladies, it's ladies night today.
It's ladies day morning on
the Monday morning podcast.
I should have a ladies' morning. Should
I, a ladies night on the Monday morning,
you know,
and I'll play clips.
I should do that and just be honoring
you while I fucking just trash you.
Am I own roundabout conti waste.
That's what I'll do. I'll just play.
Yeah. Okay. All right.
I'm back. I just ran out of
battery power. God dammit.
I was on a nice roll there. That always
makes the editing difficult. I apologize.
Everybody the fuck happened. Um, you
know what's funny too is I went and I,
and I bought a whole bunch
of these two Aa batteries,
you know,
I'm like
girls, I said we need more travel
aid batteries. He by Aa batteries,
I'm always using them.
Right.
So I go down to the Goddamn cvs and I buy
like this big fucking 12 pack of them.
12 AA batteries.
I go up to the package just like one
left fucking God damn fucking women.
Yeah. No matter what you buy,
it's not enough. It's never a fun.
I just go take a battery out of some
God damn thing that she owns. No,
not a vibrator. Yes.
Fucking filthy assholes.
So actually this baby monitor so we
can watch the dog in here. Which crate?
Training the motherfucker.
Um,
so we sit here and watch this.
Why we couldn't just use our
laptops and skyped it, you know,
sent the signal up to the
fucking satellite, whatever.
Let's get back on track here. I swear
to God, if I bought the 24 pack,
they would still only be one left.
Okay.
Well, I just replaced the batteries
and everything just in case.
Why is it illegal to slap
you? Okay, let's plow.
That's so me. I would
never do that. Okay ladies,
let's relax. All right, so let's,
let's plow ahead yet. Let me,
let me get through the advice here so
I can watch the Monday night football,
what you guys are probably already
doing. Um, so anyway, so this guy here,
so as time went on and got my confidence,
I started doing well,
I reserve the right. Uh Oh.
Anyways, he said, you know,
I didn't become cocky or start acting
like I'm God's gift to women because I
know, um, you know, I'm not that
mentality and it's for dickheads. Uh,
so anyways, this guy has been through
a considerable amount of women.
I'm trying to paraphrase here
cause this is a really long email.
He ends up meeting, meeting this
girl, everything's going great.
Um, he's having a good time with her.
After some time, this guys from Ireland,
he says after some time,
uh,
the blow jobs in sex altogether
had started to diminish.
I had a paraphrase cause he
wrote a ton of information there.
Basically he meets this girl,
everything's going great.
They basically drinking and fucking, and
everything's often, and then you know,
it starts tapering off. So, uh,
that's how it starts tapering off.
And she started to use sex as a weapon.
Uh,
she play mental games with me and it,
and I end up feeling like a bastard
when she'd shoot me down for sex,
I'd say that's cool. I don't
mind that. I excuse myself.
Go to the bathroom and crack one out.
There you go sir. That's what you do.
You know when, when you
get to that fucking Kevin
Spacey, Beautiful Mind Level,
you rub one out right in front of her.
Never.
I've never done that, but I think that,
that's awesome. Um, anyways, Egos.
Um, so anyways, I still got to Yampa
the barrel, but she wasn't involved.
And when I tried to talk to
her calmly about what she was,
see what she was thinking and how she
was feeling, it would never go well.
She returned on the waterworks
and play the victim,
even though she was the one who
instigated the mind fucking,
I'm not sure what her reject objective
was because the concept of emotional
blackmail is a foreign concept to me.
Um,
I had always tried to approach everything
with the rational under understanding
basis so that she wouldn't feel
targeted or threatened. Um,
I should also add that it took a lot
for me to sit down calmly and talk while
accepting criticism from her as I'm
a very direct in often angry fella.
Well, that's the only red
flag there. Other than that,
you seem like you take your
shit and you give it as well.
Now you got to watch the anger. Do, trust
me, I can speak volumes of that. Uh,
I'm not the best guy in the world,
so you can imagine how difficult it was,
not the puncher in her cunt face. Okay.
This is getting a little uglier. Uh,
as soon as she started crying,
as I see crying as a school yard
scapegoat for girls to get what they want
because they know men don't know
how to handle it. All right.
I'm with you with everything
right up to there.
Sometimes women do cry
because they're upset.
They do have access to that
emotion more than we do.
And I know, but I know that angry
feeling you have where you're like,
this is how you have to
gauge that is basically,
if they cry every time,
then you can call bullshit.
But if they only cry once
in a fucking Blue Moon,
then you have to realize that
you've really upset them and yeah.
And then you just got to deal with that.
That fucking awkwardness of not knowing
what to do and then also feeling like a
bully.
But there's nothing worse.
I will agree with you that if your right
and you haven't done anything wrong and
then they start crying and then you know,
you can't be a dick in that moment,
but you don't,
that doesn't mean you have just cause
they're crying doesn't mean you have to
apologize if you're fucking right.
You don't have to apologize. Uh,
but there is that thing where if
you make a female cry, I mean,
if you're any sort of a guy, it's very
difficult to just stand there and be like,
what? Well, I don't give a fuck your
crying. Go ahead. Cry some more. Huh?
Like you're that guy in the Great Santini
you're gonna shed a few start bouncing
a basketball off the back of their
head. You can't be that guy. All right,
so let's plow ahead here. Um, and anyways,
females, if you want to chime in there,
uh, ladies, um, what's
the deal with the crews?
Like what percentage of it is bullshit?
Can I get an honest fucking
woman out there? I mean,
God knows guys, we have our
techniques to get out of Shit, man.
They're fucking pathetic.
And you see right through them.
And I know right now you're like,
why are you just rubbing
their fucking muffs right now?
Because that's a strategy
to win arguments.
You just keep feeding their fucking ego.
There's a lot of women out there who
really believe that guys are so fucking
dumb that they can't
get anything past him.
And that's a great place for them to
continue existing as far as I'm concerned.
Um, oh yeah. Yeah. No, we can get anything
by you. You're just fucking, yeah,
you're the fucking goddamn world police
with, you know, you have a vagina.
You fucking know everything.
Yeah. I can't get anything by you.
You are all powerful.
I bow down in front of the,
um, you know what? He
was funny about that.
Yet any magazine out there can just,
you know,
fashion magazine can just tap into their
fucking insecurities and get them to
buy the dumbest,
stupidest fucking war paid to put on
their fucking face because some amazing
[inaudible].
I don't know,
nee knocked pigeon toed fucking
drugged up Twat is wearing it,
but you can't get it out. You can't get
anything past them yet. That's great.
My voice just cracked right there.
Can't get a lake best them.
Um, I'm sorry. I'm actually getting over
a cold if you haven't, if you can't tell,
how did you get the cold bill?
Was it from traveling the country and
doing all that press notice and it's cause
I played a game of football
and the fucking rain in
street clothes before Monday
night football last week. I'm
sorry, I was amped up. Um, anyways,
let's plow ahead. So, uh,
basically this guy deals with her for the
next two fucking months and he finally
ends up just saying he woke up one day
and said, get your shape out of my flat.
This, this is over. I can't
deal with these mind games.
So where do I get to his question here?
Um, anyways, I don't have much of an ego.
I like to accept my
faults. You know, Dude,
you've said that one too many times where
I'm starting to think maybe you do and
maybe this woman is buried in a new
fucking turnip garden in your backyard.
I like to accept my faults in the mid.
What I have done is wrong and learn from
it so as not to make the same mistakes
over and over again. My question is, Bill,
how do I get them to fuck up and stop
testing my patients and how do I meet
someone who doesn't want to control
me with their bullshit games? Um,
I dunno dude. I, half of this,
I'm really going with you when you seem
like an introspective person and the
other half you're,
you've worded this kind of like a psycho.
How do you get them to up and stop testing
your pain? Like testing your patients?
That's kind of like a,
I pictured Dick Cheney type
guy saying something like that.
What the fuck do I know?
Basically,
I don't know what your problem is in
this email. Okay. You dated a girl,
she started playing mind games with you
and all it was was after two months you
were like, fuck this, pack up your
shit and get out of my life. Um,
so be one thing,
if he was still in the relationship than
I would say that you have problems but
you don't, you uh, you met a
psycho. So what I would say is, uh,
I dunno,
just stay singles.
They single right now and wait till
you find someone who doesn't, uh,
try to mind.
Fuck you.
The problem is you sound like a
younger guy and the problem is,
is what you're learning is
that the crazy girls, they,
they're really down for anything
when it comes to sex. And, uh,
that's really hard to
resist in your 20s. So, uh,
what I would say is in the future is
when you meet a girl like that is not to
get involved in a fucking
relationship, but, uh, you know,
Bang them and you know,
get your stories out because it will
prevent you from having a midlife crisis
later on in life. Am My helping
you out? I don't know. I mean,
I'm kind of giving you shit
here, but I'm also a, I'm trying,
you know what I'm really doing right here
is you're basically bearing the brunt
of the fact that I've trashed women
so much in the last 10 minutes.
I have to try to seem like I'm balanced
here and that I don't understand exactly
what the fuck you're saying. Um,
but I think, I think you're fine.
She tried to play that mind game with
you. You didn't lose your shit, you said,
according to you anyways, just
send them fine. You went in,
you rubbed one out your banker for two
fucking months and one day you're like,
what am I doing? And you just said, yeah,
pack up. You shouldn't get outta here. So,
uh,
I would not,
this woman is not a good example of a,
of a good woman. All
right? So don't try to,
don't act like all women are like this.
Like I have for a long time and like
I do every week on my podcast just for
comedic purposes.
I like trash in them.
It's fun and it's childish,
but they're not all like that.
If you're young, there's still great girls
out there. Go out and go find them and,
uh, I don't know. Make a list
of what you're looking for.
And then you also have to
realize, dude, that you know,
everybody's going to come with their
faults like you with your temper. Um,
you know, you've got your faults, so
there you go. Did they help you out?
I probably didn't.
It probably didn't help that I fucking
paraphrased your fucking email.
And then I also, uh, lost
the batteries here in my,
uh, am I God damn recorder. Uh,
am I going to end with
that with a whimper?
You guys one of your quick revenge
story. Sure. We all do a hey bill.
I'm not much for shit jokes,
but I thought you might be interested in
one of my revenge stories when I was in
high school there, this kid who was
always giving me and my friend Shit.
So we decided, uh, no wait, I just read
that wrong. When I was in high school,
there was a kid who was always
giving my friend and I shit.
So we decided we'd give
him some look at that.
What a well worded shit joke. It's got
a little foreshadowing going on there.
Perfect amount of words.
If the reader was a little bit better
than what are going to laugh. So anyways,
he goes,
ah,
he was the guy who would not people's
lunch trays out of their hands in high
school and high five
his buddies and laugh.
So he's basically like that kid who
was in the Cobra Kai in the karate kid,
whatever that actor's name is,
who played that dude all the time.
He was in back to school. He was the
Goto Dick and all those movies. Anyways,
he was the guy who would knock a link.
[inaudible] my friend and I were
known as the punk or skater kids,
which I always thought was funny since
we were just normal kids who happen to
play music and would occasionally
skateboard for transportation. Yeah.
Punk skater kids. You think that
that kid was just a football player?
I'm sure he, maybe he liked cooking also.
You didn't watch the breakfast club.
We stereotype at that age. Um, and he,
he's a Witcher, blah, blah, blah blah.
Or kids [inaudible] sorry,
I keep losing my place here or any ways
this asshole who will call Kent would
try and start fight what fights with us
in halls and would have his minions come
up and push us from behind and runaway.
Nice to see.
Nothing has changed in high school.
Um,
we honestly didn't give a shit about
those kids so we can more ignored them.
Most of the time. Um, subutex,
they were bigger than us and we didn't
feel like getting our asses kicked. Um,
but finally the day came, Ken came up,
this is where they can't take it no more.
I like this. Finally, the day came up,
can't came up to my
friend in the parking lot,
grabbed a skateboard out of his hand,
throw it on the ground and stuck his
chin out saying, hit me. Come on,
you fucking faggot.
Hit me.
Was this kid real? Was he reading from
a bed coming of age script? Mind you,
my friend has never said a fucking word
to this prick. So I go, yeah, go ahead.
Fucking Arum Kent then says to me,
uh,
you don't even want to fucking try.
I'll fucking kick your punk ass.
Jesus. This is right out
of the bully handbook. Uh,
but me being about my
friend being a smart ass,
said my punk ass or my skys
and p proceeded to scad,
dance around Kent. It was one of
the funniest things I've ever seen.
I don't know what scar dancing is.
Is that the move in that moment and is it,
are you to get to and reinvent the
personal computer? Is this one,
this is what I see in your future.
Anyways, let's continue on with this.
Here are that night we went to Taco bell
to get some food and decided to take
revenge. We each took our to go
bags the bathroom and looked.
It took one of the most
satisfying shits of our lives.
So you guys sitting in different stalls
snickering at the son of your own shit
hitting a plastic bag. There's
a lot of layers to this. Uh,
this movie here, it's got the classic
bully. It's got the two nerds.
They're bonding, sort of got a scat
theme to it with a little scar dancing.
You know, if you, if
you write a treatment,
you could probably get it made in
this weird economy out here and now in
Hollywood are let's plow
to get a plow ahead.
Here are we put the bags of
shit in the trunk of my car.
Please tell me you double bagged and drove
over to, and at this point, this kid,
so into the story,
he actually writes this kid's real name,
but we'll still call him
Kent. Uh, we emptied a,
emptied the bags of shit into his mailbox
while trying not to throw up from the
smell.
The combination of our shit almost made
a slurry and was leaking out of the
sides of the mailbox.
Jesus Christ.
We sped out of the neighborhood but didn't
get too far because we both laughing
so fucking hard.
I can barely keep the vehicle on the road.
The next week at school I heard some kids
talking about what happened to Kent's
mailbox. I couldn't help but smile
every time someone mentioned it.
And from then on,
Ken's new nickname at school was shitbox.
Ah, am I hope you enjoyed
my disgusting story. But uh,
I'm not usually one for revenge or shit.
Jokes with this asshole deserved it.
I love the podcasts. All right,
well there you go. That's one way.
And once he supposed to do,
we can't kick the shit out of him.
So he shits in a bag with his friend
and they dump it into his mailbox.
Ah, there you go. People
were going to end on that.
We're going to end on that.
The dungeons and dragons revenge story.
Um, I mean, well, what happened?
Did you ever find out why
that is unsatisfying to me?
Did can't go out there in reaching for
his bully magazine and got a handful of
our combined shit from the
two of you or it is poor mom.
You know, where to carry that
bully around in is in her,
in her womb for nine months.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what to do with it.
I got all thrown off with my fucking,
the whole thing out of the goddamn tape
recorded crapping out on me. Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Ended on a whimper rather than a roar.
Thanks to everybody who listens to the
[inaudible] podcast and a Monday morning
podcast. Please go to the [inaudible]
podcast.com please buy my new special,
um, let it go on DVD by a couple
of them. Show your support.
God bless you. And, uh, if you
want the, Oh, Jesus ringtone,
if he can't afford a DVD,
I fucking understand that it's
a crazy economy right now.
I'm just go to the MN podcast.com
and for 99 cents, you can get the,
oh Geez, ring tone. And if you
can't afford that, who gives a fuck?
Come back next week and you have another
free podcast. All right? Once again,
thanks to everybody who helped
me try to hide my special, uh,
I'm going to go watch the saints
top the
[inaudible].